small countries sandwiched between two
major Powers don't normally have a good
time such as when Poland was carved up
between Austria Russia and Prussia or
when Roman Persia would take turns in
controlling Armenia yet despite sitting
between China and India for centuries
Nepal and Bhutan were never annexed into
either which raises the obvious question
why not why weren't bhutano Nepal ever
annexed well to begin between these two
independent states used to live a third
called sikim over the centuries the
three had been to war with their
neighbors and they Rose and fell in
power as of the 18th century to their
souths at the Mughal Empire which was an
expansionist state but one which at that
point had a lot of internal problems but
also much larger enemies to confront one
which would take advantage if the
mughals ever marched North to conquer
the Himalayan States the mughals soon
collapsed and were replaced by divided
India much of which would soon fall
under the maratha Empire but it wouldn't
be long until another Imperial power
would dominate the area the British
didn't have the manpower to hold the
entire subcontinent and so it operated a
policy of rule through the native lives
this was where local rulers already in
place would keep their positions so long
as they swore to be loyal to Britain or
before that the East India Company as
the British were expanding their
influence in the region so was Nepal and
this soon brought the two into conflict
the British primarily wanted to trade
with China via the Himalayan State The
Nepalese said no a wall was fought the
British won and in return for trade
concessions Nepal and sakim retained
their independence with a British
guarantee on the condition that Britain
would gain trade access and sakim would
soon afterwards become a protectorate
Bhutan wasn't conquered by the British
either for one simple reason mild
confusion when they first turned up the
British had no idea where China ended
and whether or not Bhutan was a part of
it they found out that it wasn't and so
invade they did the British couldn't
control the entire State and so in the
end it got the lands of Darjeeling in
return for a yearly stipend after this
though the British were happy to have
another buffer State and after the
British left the region the pool and
Bhutan were both independent and so
neither were asked to join India or
Pakistan whereas since the Keem was a
British protectorate it became an Indian
one and in the 1970s it formally joined
the country so what about China to the
North China claimed the Himalayan States
as extensions of Tibet which had been a
Chinese puppet state since the early
18th century 50 years later Nepal
invaded one the Qing retaliated and when
they won the pool was forced to pay an
annual tribute they never conquered the
territory because one conquering a
mountain state is very difficult and two
it was on the other side of a very
reluctant client state which meant
maintaining control there would be very
difficult and soon Nepal would be
brought into the British sphere of
influence and thus the Qing and later
the Chinese Republic saw no benefit in
evading Bhutan staying independent of
China is largely the same it was
geographically very difficult to hold
had close relations with Tibet and
conquering it wouldn't provide much in
benefits and furthermore when the
British turned up and brought Bhutan
into its fear of influence annexation
would mean War obviously the Chinese
were very concerned that Britain would
continue to expand its influence to
Tibet and so when Britain offered
recognition China annexed Tibet instead
happy to temporarily lose these to
permanently gain a much greater and mass
and after the Communists took power in
the country maolade claimed to all of
these as extensions of Tibet but even
after the British left China took no
action against these countries meaning
that both of them would remain
independent I hope you enjoyed this
episode and a special thanks to my
patrons James bizonette Kelly moneymaker
Sky Chappelle kosher wolf Jerry lambden
Jordan Longley Adam Stalter Marcus
arsner why in hockey Spencer Lightfoot
rod D Martin words about books podcast
Captain side dog Gustav Swan Marvin
cassau commune Winston caywood boogly
Wiggly Daniel to be in Miss izet Matthew
Shipley Aaron the white Corey Turner the
macquapa Alex Schwinn Anthony Beckett
Coppertone Maggie Paskowski she went in
spinning three plates and Charles the
first